- Hi guys, I'm Noah Centineo,
I'm here at BuzzFeed.
I'm gonna be telling you
about my first experiences.
(upbeat funk music)
All right, well, I'm
just gonna dive right in.
First cellphone.
Okay, so my parents were never on board
with the idea that of
us having cellphones,
but I was lucky because when I was 11,
I went a performing arts school
that was really far away
from where we lived,
so, not really far away,
but far enough away
that I had to take the train
to school, public transit,
so they bought me a Verizon Chocolate.
You could slide it up and you could text,
or you slide it back down
and it had little touch tones
on it, it was fantastic.
First cellphone.
First AIM account name, ah.
Oh, God, what was my
first AIM account name?
(crickets chirping)
No, noahgc@aol.com.
I used to love that.
That's where I used to
get all my music from,
the top 10, top five.
I remember Pon De Replay was
on that and like One, Two Step
and they put the videos up
and we were like, "Oh, it was so cool."
Yup, I think Hilary Duff was
on that all the time as well.
Best first date?
So this was when I lived at The W.
The W Hotel resident side
has a really cool rooftop.
Sweet pool, big W.
She'd come over late afternoon
sometime close to sunset or just before
and I said bring a book and we traded.
I gave her Celestine Prophecy
and she gave me You Are
The One by Kute Blackson
and we read for like three hours.
I love being sentimental
and remembering things,
it's likes I literally am a sentimentalist
and that's all I do so this is fantastic.
First pet?
Oh, I think it was a
rabbit named Princess.
Yeah, and then we got a dog
and the dog ate the rabbit,
(laughs)
(record scratches)
and that was the end of the first pet,
it was the first death I
had ever really experienced
was the first pet. (laughs)
This is morbid.
We're out.
Okay, last one.
First time realizing you were famous?
I was 15 years old, I had
just moved to Los Angeles,
I was at the AMC Movie Theater
in Century City with my mom.
We were walking through the lobby
and these girls came
up to me and they said,
"Are you Dallas from Austin & Ally,
"do you play the cellphone
accessory cart guy?"
And I was like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,"
and they were like, "Can we
have a picture with you?"
And I was like, "Yeah, of
course, like sure, thank you,"
and we took pictures
and my mom was kind of just
standing there and beaming
and I was like dang.
Dang.
Alright guys, my name's Noah Centineo.
You can check out some of the stuff
that's coming out on Netflix,
Sierra Burgess Is A Loser
and To All The Boys I
Loved Before, please do it.
We're here at Buzzfeed,
that's all my time with you,
I love you guys so much,
thank you for tuning it,
I hope to be back here and
see you guys very soon.
Deuces.
(laughs)
- [Crew Member] Great.
(light music)
(squeaking)